what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it looks like the
new Avengers team is about to assemble
and it's about time we've gone a pretty
long time now without an official
Avengers team in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe after Avengers end game and
really after Captain America Civil War
The Avengers kind of disbanded and
Disney even came out after the events of
Avengers endgame and stated yes right
now in the Marvel Cinematic Universe we
don't really have an Avengers team and
that of course is because a new Avengers
team has to be formed officially and
that has not happened yet however it is
about to happen and it sounds like we're
about to get our next little Captain
America Civil War type of movie our next
Little Avengers mini film and I want to
clarify obviously we are getting
Avengers the King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars those are obviously not many
Avengers films those are true fully
blown out out Avengers films what I'm
talking about is a film like Captain
America Civil War it wasn't an Avengers
film but it basically had all of the
Avengers in there minus Thorn Hulk that
is what we are about to get however this
will not be a civil war well kind of
this is not going to be the Avengers
versus The Avengers but it looks like
it's going to be the Avengers versus the
United States kind of because as it
turns out no big surprise here
Thunderbolt Ross AKA Red Hulk isn't
exactly going to be that good of a guy
slashed that good of a president and it
looks like it might be up to our new
Captain America Sam Wilson and the new
Avengers to take him down we have some
really awesome details about this today
that we're about to break down and if
you're new be sure to subscribe to the
channel to stay up to date and if you
want to enter our giveaway all you got
to do is subscribe and leave a comment
down below for your chance to win an
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items we pick one
winner at the end of each month and the
winner gets to pick one item so we've
had a lot of details come out recently
about Captain America 4 and from what
we've heard this is going to be sort of
a mini Avengers film like Captain
America 3 was kind of keeping up with
tradition here but according to some
reports from some insiders this is going
to be the film where the new Avengers
team is assembled and Sam Wilson's
Captain America will seek a new Avengers
team for the specific cause of taking on
Thunderbolt Ross slash Red Hulk now we
all know that Thunderbolt Ross in the
comics is the Red Hulk but many people
are wondering if Thunderbolt Ross who is
now played by Harrison Ford because
unfortunately William Hurt passed away
is actually going to become the Red Hulk
in the film well according to multiple
different insiders yes he is indeed
going to become Red Hulk in the film and
this won't be kept a secret during
marketing that specific part is coming
from The Insider can we get some toast
and that basically means that in the
trailer maybe not the teaser trailer but
the full official trailer we will see
Red Hulk or if not we'll see him in some
promotional images and posters but I
would be really surprised if we didn't
see him in the full official trailer now
before we dive into who is going to be a
part of the new Avengers team that Sam
Wilson assembles we obviously have to
address why they are assembling right
now in this specific film at this
specific time and that is because of
President Thunderbolt Russ he will
become president in this film so this
film is really going to be about three
different things one Thunderbolt Ross
and taking him down to tayamat Island
and the search for adamantium which
apparently is what the celestial Tiamat
is made out of and now the USA and all
the other countries of the world are
fighting for tayamat Island and
specifically they are fighting for
adamantium because they believe it could
be even more valuable than vibranium and
of course since we're mentioning
adamantium we're getting into X-Men
Wolverine territory here which is just
super exciting but three the film is
also going to be about super Soldier
serum which makes a lot of sense this is
picking up after the events of the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier and Sam
Wilson did not want to take the Super
Soldier serum however we know that
Thunderbolt Ross has been trying to
recreate this for a very long time now
so this is a very fitting plot point for
this film and based off of what we heard
Sam Wilson is going to go Toe to Toe
with Thunderbolt Ross as the Red Hulk
and a lot of people ask well if he
doesn't have the super soldier serum how
exactly is he going to fight a Hulk and
the answer is vibranium and wakandan
Technology apparently our new Captain
America is going to get a new suit that
is going to be made entirely of
vibranium so not only will he have the
vibranium Shield but the suit should be
able to absorb and release energy much
like a black panther suit in fact
Insider can we get some toast on
Instagram said don't sleep on Sam Wilson
with that wakandan technology it'll
definitely help even the odds when
fighting against a Hulk so no doubt this
will be an excellent battle that I'm
sure a lot of people are going to look
forward to but as I mentioned Sam Wilson
is going to be asking for some help and
that is going to come in the form of the
new Avengers team now we haven't heard
any specifics on how this team is
actually physically assembled in the
film but we do know who Marvel has
hinted to us is going to be a part of
the new Avengers team and we know what
some insiders have said as well so far
this is what we know Sam Wilson's
Captain America will indeed be the
leader of the new Avengers team he'll be
joined by Joaquin Torres who is going to
be the new Falcon and we met him
previously in the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier Bucky will not be on the team
he's going to be on the Thunderbolts
team so that's going to be completely
different but we have heard that Wong is
going to be on the team right now he is
the sorcerer Supreme so that makes sense
we've also heard of course Shang Chi is
going to be joining the new Avengers
team Wong has actually already recruited
Shang Chi so again this just makes sense
She-Hulk is reportedly going going to be
on the new Avengers team and of course
our friendly multiversal Spider-Man now
keep in mind more people will join the
new Avengers team just most likely not
in Captain America Brave New World
remember it's supposed to be kind of a
mini Avengers team so other characters
like Captain Marvel will eventually join
the team in Avengers King Dynasty which
is a full-blown Avengers film so there
we'll get Captain Marvel Doctor Strange
Ant-Man especially if you consider his
recent dealings with King the Conqueror
freeze banners Hulk will join Thor will
presumably join and of course Doctor
Strange will get in the fight as well it
is important to note that a lot of the
newer younger characters will be a part
of a Young Avengers team not necessarily
joining the actual New Avengers team
when they are assembled in the MCU
however something really cool that we've
heard recently about Avengers Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars is there are
going to be multiple Avengers teams kind
of like Avengers subunits there will be
teams like Moon Knight and blade and
Wanda Supernatural people kind of taking
on a specific version of King the
Conqueror while our new Avengers take on
another version of Kang and perhaps
another Cosmic side takes on a different
version of King as well since there are
crazy amounts of Kang variants this
simply makes sense but for Captain
America Brave New World They're Gonna
Keep It relatively simple and keep in
mind Sam Wilson is going to be the one
recruiting them so I'm not sure if he
has the means to get in touch with
Captain Marvel if she is somewhere
across the Galaxy but he does know how
to find She-Hulk he knows how to find
Peter Parker and I'm imagining somehow
he gets in touch with Wong who of course
knows how to get in touch with Shang Chi
now apparently Thunderbolt Ross is doing
some pretty shady stuff reactivating the
super soldier program which of course
Sam Wilson does not want to be
reactivated and no doubt he's planning
to do something with adamantium perhaps
this could be the start of the weapon x
program and if Captain America gets a
hold of this finds out that this is what
he wants to do I'm sure he's gonna have
a big problem with this as well because
remember Sam Wilson is our new Captain
America he has that sense of morality
that's who Captain America is even if it
is now Sam Wilson him and Steve Rogers
shared a lot of the same views and he is
now going to hold that title of Captain
America so it is his job and sense of
Duty to do what is right now there are
some unknown characters that could join
the battle in Brave New World like
Roadie but his story is kind of a mess
right now apparently he has been a
scroll since the last mini Avengers film
Captain America Civil War when he got
hurt Apparently that is when he was
replaced by a scroll we're really unsure
about what armor Wars is going to be
about right now given the fact that
Roadie hasn't really been in the scene
or his actual position in years so we're
kind of unsure right now if Rody's going
to want to just jump right back into the
War Machine and start taking on the
president of the United States who is
also a Hulk but he is definitely a
candidate for the new Avengers team in
Captain America 4 that is no way he
skips out on the battle in Avengers Kang
Dynasty and singer Wars he's definitely
going to be in those another candidate
is Daredevil he is going to be making
his return to the MCU for the third time
now the first time we didn't really see
Daredevil we just saw Matt Murdock and
Spider-Man no way home then of course we
saw the true Daredevil and She-Hulk and
now he is returning in his own show
Daredevil born again this is coming out
before Captain America Brave New World
at least that's how it was planned
before with the strikes and everything
going on we're not really sure the exact
release date of Daredevil born again
right now but it's supposed to be early
2024 and Captain America Brave New World
is supposed to be coming out July 26th
of 2024 so we should get Daredevil
before it which makes him a candidate
for this new Avengers team that Sam
Wilson will assemble in Captain America
Brave New World so there are just a ton
of exciting factors that are going to be
a part of Captain America Brave New
World we're going to get a red Hulk we
are going to get adamantium in the MCU
we are going to get the super soldier
serum program trying to be started again
and of course we're going going to get
our first glimpse of a new Avengers team
so let us know how excited you are for
Captain America Brave New World in the
comments down below and if you have a
set of Avengers you would want to be a
part of the new Avengers team let us
know that list in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news you can also find us
on patreon you can check out our website
and find us on Discord and of course you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
as well and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf